when you add a base.
Ends Labor Day.
♪ ♪
>> THEY ARE LOOTERS AND WRITERS,
AND ANY HERE THE DEMOCRATS, THEY
NEVER SAY ANYTHING ABOUT THEM.
NEVER MENTIONING LAW AND ORDER
OR THE WORD POLICE.
>> THERE ARE A LOT OF FOLKS THAT
FELT THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS MADE
GREAT STRIDES WITH THIS -- LAW
AND ORDER STRIDE.
AND BOY, AFTER HIS CONVENTION,
HE REALLY -- WE REALLY MADE AND
ROADS.
HE HAS SENT.
NOT AT ALL.
I AM BEING SERIOUS.
THIS SHOULD GIVE YOU A LITTLE
BIT OF CONFIDENCE.
IN THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, THEY ARE
NOT BUYING IT.
>> Bret: JOE BIDEN IN KENOSHA,
WISCONSIN TODAY, THE FAMILY OF
JACOB BLAKE THROUGH
ATTORNEY GENERAL SAYING
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN COMING AND
JILL BIDEN HAD AN IN PERSON
MEETING WITH THE FAMILY.
THEY WERE GRATEFUL AND IMPRESSED
THAT THEY WERE SO ENGAGED AND
WILLING TO REALLY LISTEN.
THEY TALK ABOUT THE CHANGING IN
THE TREATMENT OF MINORITIES AND
POLICE INTERACTIONS, THE IMPACT
OF SELECTING KAMALA HARRIS AS A
BLACK WOMAN AND RUNNING MATE,
AND VICE PRESIDENTS CHANGE.
IT WAS VERY CLEAR THAT BIDEN
CARED AS HE EXTENDED JACOB JR.
HUMANITY, AND WORTHY OF PRAYER,
TALKING DIRECTLY TO JACOB BLAKE
IN -- BY PHONE, LET’S BRING IN
THE PANEL, OPINION WRITER FOR
"THE WASHINGTON POST,"
KIMBERLEY STRASSEL, MEMBER OF
THE EDITORIAL BOARD, JONAH
GOLDBERG, EDITOR IN CHIEF OF THE
DISPATCH.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT’S TRIP TODAY, AND
PERHAPS THE CONTRAST TO THE
PRESIDENT’S TRIP YESTERDAY.
>> WELL, TO ME IT IS NOTABLE
THAT HE IS IN WISCONSIN AND THAT
HE IS ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES,
BECAUSE THERE ARE TWO THINGS
THAT THE CAMPAIGN WAS NOT
WILLING TO DO A COUPLE OF WEEKS
AGO AND THEY HAD A VIRTUAL
CONVENTION AND THEY DID NOT
REALLY WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
SUBJECT.
SO WHEN YOU CHANGE STRATEGY IT
MEANS THAT YOU ARE WORRIED AND
IN SOME WAY DESPITE JOE BIDEN
SAYING THAT HE DOES NOT THINK
THAT THE PRESIDENT IS MAKING
INROADS ON THE LAW AND ORDER
THING, THE FACT THAT HE IS OUT
THERE DOING IT SUGGEST THAT
DEMOCRATS ARE WORRIED.
AND WE WILL SEE WHERE THAT GOES,
BUT I THINK IT’S SOMETHING THAT
HE IS GOING TO HAVE TO ADDRESS,
BECAUSE PEOPLE KEEP WATCHING TV
AND THERE IS NO LONGER ANY MORE
DENYING THAT THIS IS BECOMING A
HUGE PROBLEM AND CITIES IN THE
SUBURBAN COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
>> Bret: THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN’S
RESPONSE AND WRITTEN STATEMENT
SAYING JOE BIDEN MADE A
POLITICAL TRIP TODAY.
HIS FIRST VISIT TO WISCONSIN
AFTER MONTHS OF SAYING HE COULD
NOT TRAVEL BECAUSE OF THE
SCIENCE AND THE CORONAVIRUS PAID
WHAT CHANGE WAS POLITICAL
SCIENCE AS HE KNOWS HE IS IN A
SERIOUS DECLINE IN THE POLLS.
PEOPLE PARTICIPATING IN HIS
CHURCH MEETING WERE HANDED
SCRIPTS TO READ FROM DURING THE
PUBLIC PERIOD, PROVING THAT HIS
HANDLERS DO NOT TRUST HIM AND
UNCONTROLLED SITUATIONS.
NONETHELESS AMERICANS DID NOT
HEAR ANY DENUNCIATION OF ANTIFA
OR LEFT-WING AGITATORS WHO HAVE
RIOTED IN AMERICAN CITIES FROM
COAST TO COAST.
SAYING NOTHING ABOUT WISCONSIN
GOVERNORS EITHER TO QUELL THE
RIOTS AND DID NOT EXPLAIN THAT
HE OPPOSED CALLING IN THE
NATIONAL GUARD TO PROTECT
AMERICANS FROM VIOLENCE
LEFT-WING WRITERS.
HE MADE THE ABOVEGROUND
EXCURSION FROM HIS BASEMENT FOR
PURELY POLITICAL REASONS AND IT
SHOWS.
WE BOTH HAVE READ THOSE
STATEMENTS.
CHUCK, YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> THAT WAS A POLITICAL
STATEMENT.
I MEAN, THE PRESIDENT IS -- HAS
NOT BEEN EMPHATIC IN DENOUNCING
SORT OF THE RIGHT-WING PEOPLE AS
A WAY TO KIND OF -- YOU KNOW,
EXTENUATING THE SITUATION, BUT
LOOK, THIS IS AN ABSOLUTE --
HE STARTED WHICH WAS AS A
PEACEMAKER, REMEMBER, THE IMAGE
THAT HE POSTED IN
CHARLOTTESVILLE, THE TERRIBLE
VIOLENCE, HE THOUGHT THAT I WAS
THE WORST THAT IT COULD BE.
IT WASN’T.
THAT TERRIBLE CONFLICT, BETWEEN
RIGHT AND LEFT, ULTIMATELY SOME
OF THE PEOPLE ON THE LIBERAL
SIDE, ONE OF THEM WAS KILLED BY
A RIGHT-WING PERSON DRIVING A
CAR, AND SO, I THINK THAT IN HIS
VIEW IT’S THE STRENGTH OF HIS
CAMPAIGN.
HE IS VIEWED AS SOMEBODY WHO IS
MORE PEACEFUL, MORE UNIFYING,
MORE STABILIZING AND THAT’S HOW
HE GOT INTO THIS THING.
I THINK THAT THIS IS HIM TAKING
AN OPPORTUNITY TO GET BACK TO
HOW IT STARTED.
>> Bret: CLEARLY THE LAWN
ISSUE ORDER IN DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES.
THERE HAS BEEN A SHIFT, BUT THE
POLLS ARE THE SAME PLACE THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN OVER ALL IF YOU
LOOK AT ALL OF THE KEY
BATTLEGROUND STATES.
>> YEAH, I MEAN, I AGREE WITH
BOTH KIM AND CHUCK AND DIFFERENT
ASPECTS.
LOOKING AT THE STATEMENT, OF
COURSE JOE BIDEN IS IN WISCONSIN
FOR POLITICAL PURPOSES, HE IS
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT IN THE
UNITED STATES.
HE IS NOT GOING TO TRAVEL
ANYWHERE THAT IS NOT FOR A
POLITICAL PURPOSE RIGHT NOW.
AND NEITHER FRANKLY IS
DONALD TRUMP.
I DON’T THINK THAT THAT LANDS
TOO HARD, BUT WHERE I THINK KIM
IS RIGHT IS THAT THE LAW AND
ORDER MESSAGE HAS SOME PURPOSE.
AND NOT AS MUCH AS THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN THINKS IT DOES, BUT THE
SIMPLE FACT IS THAT IT WAS --
THAT JOE BIDEN WAS A LITTLE SLOW
IN ANTICIPATING THAT THIS WAS
SOMETHING THAT HE WOULD HAVE TO
RESPOND TO.
AND I ACTUALLY THINK THAT HIS
STATEMENTS HAVE BEEN PRETTY GOOD
ON THIS STUFF, HE IS CONDEMNING
VIOLENCE.
HE IS NOT USING THE LANGUAGE
THAT THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN WANTS
HIM TO USE, NOR IS DONALD TRUMP
USING THE LANGUAGE THAT THE
BIDEN CAMPAIGN SAYS HE SHOULD
USE.
SO WHERE WE ARE IS THAT THIS HAS
BEEN ONE OF THE MOST STABLE
RACES IN MODERN MEMORY, THE LEAD
HAS BEEN REMARKABLY STABLE,
DONALD TRUMP’S BASE HAS BEEN
REMARKABLY STABLE, AND I REALLY
THINK AT THIS POINT THE ONLY
THING THAT WE CAN PLAN ON REALLY
SHAKING THE NUMBERS IN A
SIGNIFICANT WAY ARE THE DEBATES.
BECAUSE THE CONVENTION DID NOT
DO IT.
>> Bret: THE OTHER NEWS THAT
WAS A PART OF THE SLIDE IS THE
VACCINE TALK AND WHETHER THERE
WILL BE A VACCINE AT THE END
OF NOVEMBER OR OCTOBER BEGINNING
IN NOVEMBER, HERE IS THE
WHITE HOUSE AND TONY FAUCI,
KIMBERLY.
>> DR. FAUCI SAID THERE WAS NO
PRESSURE THAT I’VE SEEN TO MOVE
QUICKLY, THE PRESIDENT WANTS TO
BREAK THROUGH REGULATORY
BARRIERS TO GET TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
BECAUSE LIVES ARE AT STAKE.
>> THERE IS A KIND OF THING THAT
PEOPLE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT.
IT WILL BECOME PUBLIC SOONER OR
LATER.
SO I THINK THAT WE CAN HAVE SOME
CONFIDENCE AND HAVE FAITH IN
WHAT THE FDA IS SAYING.
THEY ARE SAYING VERY EXPLICITLY
THAT THEY ARE GOING TO BE MAKING
THE DECISION BASED ON THE
SCIENTIFIC DATA, AND WE HOPE
THAT THAT IS GOING TO BE THE
CASE.
>> Bret: BEING ASKED ABOUT THE
FACT WOULD THERE BE
CONSIDERATION GETTING THE
VACCINE OUT BEFORE ELECTION DAY,
KIMBERLY.
>> THIS COMES FROM THE THEORY
THAT YOU HAVE BEEN HEARING
INCREASINGLY ON THE LEFT THAT
THERE IS POLITICAL PRESSURE TO
RUSH THE VACCINE AND IT WILL NOT
BE SAFE.
THAT DOES NOT TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
THE FACT THAT THE VACCINES HAVE
BEEN THROUGH SAFETY TRIALS.
THIS IS LOOKING AT QUESTIONS OF
EFFICACY AT THIS POINT AND HOW
GOOD THEY ARE.
IS THERE POLITICAL PRESSURE TO
GET THIS OUT?
MOSTLY BECAUSE THEY ARE DEALING
WITH A PANDEMIC AND IT IS HAVING
A TERRIBLE CONSEQUENCE ON THE
ECONOMIC AND PERSONAL LIVES OF
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS.
WOULD IT BE POLITICALLY GOOD FOR
THE WHITE HOUSE TO ALSO HAVE IT
OUT SOONER RATHER THAN LATER?
YES, BUT AS DR. FAUCI HAS SAID
AND NO ONE HAS PROVIDED ANY
EVIDENCE OTHERWISE THAT THIS